[Musique]
surfant les oiseaux
je vous emmène aujourd'hui avec moi au
bois de boulogne
on s'est fait un petit tour en vélo en
ce fameux tour en vélo électrique
on va aujourd'hui parler de vélo à
assistance électrique voit ses couleurs
wade pouvoir faire cette vidéo filmée
poser la caméra indirecte sur le vélo
alors c'est la première fois que je
teste un vélo à assistance électrique
parle de trottinettes on parle de pleins
d'objets électrique mais celui là non et
justement ça vachement intéressant ça
fait un petit moment que je fais des
tours détours de tours de bois je me
balade il fait une chaleur il fait beau
on en plein mois de juillet c'est hyper
cool alors justement ce qu'on va faire
si je vous expliquais déjà ce qui ce
vélo astrance haïti qu'est ce qui peut
faire un truc vraiment hyper hyper hyper
hyper haut de gamme enfin un produit qui
est vraiment hallucinant qu'on peut
faire plein de trucs
la première chose c'est de pédaler mais
il ya plein de mode c'était franchement
hyper cool et puis ce constat vaut pour
me dire en commentaire ce que vous en
pensez
[Musique]
la marque c'est reese et muller pas si
vous connaissez on est dans le très haut
de gamme au niveau des vélos vélos à
assistance électrique ça veut pas dire
que celle électrique ça veut pas dire
que vous avez pas pédaler vous devez
fournir un effort mais le vélo est là
pour vous aider comment ça marche le
truc c'est hyper simple vous avez votre
vélo vous l'allumez vous choisissez
votre mode de pilotage d'alléchants
entre plusieurs modes et ensuite vous
commencé à pédaler pour une vitesse plus
élevée vous allez fournir la même
quantité d'énergie
en gros donc vous pédalez pluie il
envoie il compensait en fonction des
modes
il va plus ou moins qu'on pensait que
vous mettez en mode eco il va compenser
au studium tu peux la cool mais ça
devrait aller
et vous passez en mode turbo là ça va
carrément tartiner en gros il va venir
vraiment vous accompagner jusqu'à une
vitesse max de 25 km heure après vous
pouvez aller plus vite mais par contre
c'est à vous de fournir l'énergie
supplémentaire
[Musique]
le panneau de contrôle et votre vélo se
présente comme ça bon ici vous avez
votre frein avant vous en douterez ici
vous avez la petite commande pour
l'écran qui est là et ça là où tous joué
salle où ça devient hyper intéressant là
le bouton pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre
bouton pour les femmes et surtout là
vous avez plusieurs modes le premier
mode vous indiquent que leur si vous
êtes en mode eco compagnie c'est ça les
phares le pourcentage de batteries
restantes la vitesse que vous avez là le
personnage batteries restantes qui est
client voit ici bluetooth haut ce que
vous pouvez synchroniser votre
smartphone qui vous êtes tout votre
config et là vous y retrouver plusieurs
modes là ici c'est votre vitesse et en
fonction du mode dans lequel vous êtes
lassés de madeco là par exemple je passe
en mode tour je passe en mode ntv l'âge
et le mode turbo
celui qui va être le plus énergivore
mais qui comme annie père rigolo le truc
vachement poule c
expérience parce que la voyait en train
de pédaler je suis à quoi à 15 km heure
je suis en mode eco et je lui donne
vraiment la cool et lui me compensent
tous s'en est pas laissé passer en mode
turbo bordel ça vous attend vous pédalez
un tout petit peu ça qu'on pense au max
abritant pas là rien c'est un peu
sauvage vous avez une petite poignée
après pour dérégler la dureté comme sur
n'importe quel vélo ça vous permet de
pédaler plus vite ou moins vite et là
avec le mode turbo franchement tâche
ça me des à-coups c'est franchement
sauvage sur ce front là vous avez
l'heure vous avez l'autonomie restante
en deux kilomètres qui bien sûr va
baisser
si vous passez en mode turbo ça va
baisser vraiment significativement
distance parcourue trajet restant estimé
bien évidemment en fonction du mode dans
lequel vous êtes la puissance la cadence
la vitesse moyenne la vitesse max que
vous avez atteindre et j'étais qu'un
hyper la kul distance l'autonomie
puissance cardio compagnie fréquence
cardiaque
un bouton ici pour vos phares pour
mettre en place phare ou alors en
fanfare normaux et bien évidemment une
partie de sa dette
[Musique]
vous ne réglez votre vitesse ici la
voyait plus vous et sans délai plus
c'est dur là là je tourne et plus je
remonte et plus c'est facile et ça
inclut mode eco massa devait fournir
forcément un peu plus d'efforts mais si
vous passez avec le mode turbo juste ouf
est ce qu'il est vraiment complètement
où vous voyez c'est que lorsque vous
allez avoir démonté par exemple que vous
tapez des petites code vous passez en
mode turbo et là vous fournissez
quasiment plus aucun effort c'est le
vélo qui fait tout enfin faut pédaler
quand même mais vraiment dans l'absolu
il faut pas pédaler énormément pour
pouvoir avancer hyper vite mais surtout
truqués ouf
avec ce vélo c'est le freinage vous avez
un frein abs à l'avant ce qui fait que
vous allez pas du tout bloqué alors je
sais pas si vous le savez si vous faites
du vélo ou pas mais en règle générale
les cyclistes il utilise pas trop le
frein avant et c'est plutôt une grosse
erreur je suis motard et lorsque vous
passer le permis moto on vous dit
utilisent 75 % le frein avant est à 25%
le frein arrière en rose est toujours en
train de freiner que le fera avant celui
qui va chemin le plus efficace c'est
vrai que les cyclistes ont toujours peur
de se dire oui mais si sereine avec
l'avant je vais passer par dessus et je
vais tomber alors que pas du tout et
c'est vrai que ce qui est vachement plus
rassurant avec ce système là c'est que
vous avez un partenariat avec bausch
c'est bosch qui équipe le moteur qui est
vraiment au top
et en plus vous avez un frein abs à
l'avant uniquement en avant avec bosch
l'idée c'est que lorsque vous allez
venir freiner avec le frein avant
la poignée gauche sur leur moto c'est la
poignée droite je comprends à chaque
fois que ça va venir
réguler perdre comme des petits à coup
ça va pas venir bloquer si vous freinez
fort ça bloque pas c'est le système de
la ds je pense que vous connaissez
pas grand chose à vous apprendre là
dessus mais c'est vachement cool et
c'est hyper rassurant pour toutes les
personnes qui effectivement ont peur
d'utiliser le frein avant et pour moi
c'est ce qu'ils arrêtent le mieux alors
bien évidemment si vous freinez avec le
frein arrière
vous avez pour faire des dérapages vous
amuser si vous voulez le faire pourrait
faire ça c'est plutôt cool par contre
vous avez quand même bouffer de la gaude
bon le truc qui est un peu moins rigolo
c'est que bien évidemment vous en
douterez il ya des options dessus et la
baisse sur le frein avant on fait partie
donc si vous voulez pouvoir avoir un
vélo électrique à de l'eau à assistance
électrique
comme chaque samedi avec de la bsa
l'avant ben il va falloir peut-être le
prix alors déjà le vélo en lui-même il
est hyper bien franchement tu pouvais
faire avec c'est vraiment génial par
contre c'est un velouté premium qui va
pas s'adresser à tout le monde on est un
peu plus de 5000 euros la lettre mais
lorsque vous racheter les options bas
tout de suite ça grimpe que vous montez
à des prix qui sont tout de suite assez
élevé après faut vraiment en avoir
l'usagé faut vraiment vouloir mettre le
prix pouvoir le mettre
mais c'est vrai que si vous pouvez vous
le permettre sept mecs là elle est
complètement ouf
et surtout moi ce que j'adore c'est au
delà de l'aspect un peu technique de la
batterie de la bs du moteur bosch et
compagnie ce qui est vraiment génial
c'est l'expérience
donc le fait de dire voilà c'est hyper
cool c'est hyper x si vous allez à la
vitesse que vous voulez vous fait
plaisir de les monter vous embêter plus
sa couleur plus rien vous avez quand
même une grosse autonomie
donc ça c'est pareil c'est vraiment un
point très positif
[Musique]
clermont ce truc c'est pas un vtt
mais l'idée c'est que on n'a pas la
sensation qu'on peut quand même passé un
peu partout avec mais ça je trouve ça
cool et comme vous avez cette assistance
ne vous embêtez pas le fait dans le vide
amant d'abord ses freins disque c'est
quand même opération la baisse à l'avant
dans ses clients dans ses opérations
surtout les amortisseurs sont hyper
costaud c'est iperflex cse moussa vous
absorbe tous les chocs le nom du vélo
ces hommages si vous intéresse je vous
ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description des chariots vous pouvez
utiliser aussi bien en ville parce qu'il
va vraiment vous aider avec le mode eco
est ce que vous voulez pour vous
déplacer dans le mode urbain c'est cool
piste cyclable bien évidemment est ce
qu'on n'a pas bien vous faites quand
même vachement gaffe ce qu'ici à paris
les gens soient un petit peu tendu quand
même avec les vélos copie les pistes
cyclables c'est pas toujours ça en
montagne c'est vachement bien parce que
ça doit vraiment vous aider lors des
côtes
ça va venir compenser vous n'allez pas
vous embêter on re pouvait l'utiliser
partout c'est vraiment un vélo qui est
hyper facile d'utilisation et surtout
qui est hyper adaptatif ont leur chariot
c'est facile vous avez ça voilà et vous
venez le brancher directement ici le
temps de recharge qui donnait pas assez
précis voilà je fais pas de bêtises
c'est par ici abraxas recharge
le temps de recharge qui donnait par
bosch pour recharger complètement votre
batterie ses 4h30 il ya un vrai confort
à venir utilise un des lots comme ça la
position est hyper agréable à lasser les
conforts gens regardent sans leur site
les différents tarifs ils commencent à
5099 hommage et et touring c'est vrai
que c'est quand même un certain certain
budget après à côté de ça le c'est un
produit premium et les finitions sont
vraiment vraiment super je vous le dis
hein c'est un produit qu'il faut pouvoir
se permettre de s'offrir
je trouve que vraiment c'est un
excellent produit alors bien évidemment
ça c'est je pense qu'à ce cas là toute
façon on se doit d'avoir un excellent
produit mais à mon avis si vous avez le
budget si vous voulez si vous pouvez ça
ne regretterez pas je sais pas comment
vous le trouvez vous est ce que c'est un
truc qui pourrait vous intéresser
est-ce que tu allais me de partout de la
paille qui est ce que c'est un produit
qui pourrait vous intéresser est-ce que
vous avez un vélo à assistance
électrique est ce que c'est un truc qui
vous intéresse alors c'est vrai que il
ya une vraie problématique déjà en
termes de déplacements dans les vignes
notamment en termes de pollution est
vrai que ce genre de produits c'est une
bonne alternative même si effectivement
aujourd'hui on n'a pas encore trouvé la
solution vraiment adapté pour le
recyclage des batteries attendant on
n'aimait pas
de gaz à effet de serre dont bon ça
c'est quand même moindre mal moi je
trouve ça cool j'aime bien ce vélo je
trouve cool a vous de me dire maintenant
ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous utilisez un vélo à
assistance électrique est ce que vous
utilisez un moyen pour vous déplacer
électrique sur une trottinette que ce
soit ce que vous voulez pour marquer
tous à gagner derrière c'est un petit
truc vous avez le plan avec la tour
eiffel on est pas mal aux bad boy voilà
vous marquez tout ça je vais les gros
becs un bisou et puis on se voit très
vite à demain ciao
[Musique]